I come into this video for round form of
the Zurich chest challenge I'm actually
asking myself every time I'm announcing
that right is called the chest challenge
well let's go go to the games round form
first game I'm going to look at his girl
font against holland the two contenders
of the 2012 World Championship match and
they both have real bad tournament
certainly hoping to get a win here let's
see what happened we have a sloth
defense and intact we get exactly the
same position as yesterday in the game
koala against Ireland oh she has got two
blacks in a row and we had exactly the
same yesterday after g4 Bishop g6
Caruana captured on d5 after which
island play tonight xe5 and we had a
complicated game where it looked like
whites maybe had a little something but
also honored them had his chances and at
the end term played a draw Gelfond
displaying differently placed night 2h
form this is quite similar to 95 in them
the same idea to take on g6 getting the
bishops in general White's play in this
some slow Slav as it caught with e3 this
kind of line is very often get to add
some the bishop and the bishop on g6
here in this case is outside of the pawn
chain and white will take it at some
point and then try to prove that his two
bishops account for something Black's
compensation is the absolute yeah
solidity of his position he's got yeah
very rock solid position in the center
we see that after a couple of moves
look quite normal yeah a five I think
this is a good idea announcer move here
it tries to push the apron up the board
and this is in a way asking white well
where are you going to put your king
after h3 and g4 it's quite clear that
white won't Castle short anymore it
stopped totally out of the question but
very unlikely with G for being played
and they love that stop possible where
do you go keeping it in the center some
tricky and if you can so long there's
the age the a pawn to worry about we see
that after this why took on d5 if he m
place um yeah an innocent-looking move
like a let's say Bishop d3 there's the
spawn hanging so it's not so easy at the
moment to develop him if you play moves
like that you also have to reckon with a
four again the trick is that after this
capture black takes and then takes on c4
and any capture on c4 needs to be five
which in turn gets right into big
trouble the King on d 2 is also very
unhealthy a4 is a good way to gain
counter play I think galfond solution is
not bad at all he took on d5 and played
f3 this is a bit slow but it control
it's important squares and pawns it
secures g-form so the black cannot take
it and it secures the e4 square which is
very important blacks night was always
longing to get to the square and with f3
that's not possible anymore yeah a form
this was planned all along what happens
if Y it now takes on a form always need
to check that it's a answered by okay
for and white will
yeah wyd will really suffer him I have a
look at this check losing instantly you
cannot take that so Quincy to back they
only move and now a 3 and this is some
very nice plan this a pawn push now this
a three-pound will always be near the
White King after long castles we see
that white castles long where else to go
you needed to cancel long there's not
much else and here this pawn is a
constant very for white in even in the
deep end game this can be a problem like
the Queen appearing near the king
checkmate on be to view this is very far
away but something to to take into
account if some pieces not the Queen's
if some pieces I exchanged like some
some minor pieces the rooks then this
spawn can be a real problem for white
and it will be the cornerstone of blacks
clown to play all the time and I'm not
saying why this worse it's just a very
important feature of the position this
pond he castle short and O king be one
hard to do without this move in the long
run rook c8 yeah obviously trying to
play c5 if possible opening up the C
file right played H for this makes lots
of sense you need to get some play on
the King side and after Knight b6 which
young prepares also on a retreat square
muscle after Knight b6 now galphin
played g5 and I have a suggestion here
which i think is interesting instead of
g5 he also could have played h5 and this
sir yeah this looks interesting to me
it's a very typical motif you'll see
that after g5 island play tonight eh
five blocking the Kings side and if you
go after 9 p-6 h5 first after the
capture you go g5 and now there's no h 5
square the Black Knight needs to retreat
now 2h7 or d7 let's say goes to d7 then
white can think of two moves you can
take on h5 which looks very dangerous at
the first at first sight opening the H
file you need to reckon with g6 though
it's not clear that this is leading to
something decisive something like that
might be okay for black but the also is
a tribe takes G 597 there also is the
move g6 which are find interesting this
is just preventing g6 x black and it
leads to an opening of the position on
the light squares which is very
desirable for white as he's got the
light squared Bishop and the light
squared Bishop of black is already gone
for couple of moves so initiating play
on the lights class is very logical from
a positional point of view and I think
white has some dangerous play here it's
not like winning but but interesting
night f8 is such a suggestion the
intention is after rook takes h5 to take
with the pawn and at least have a palm
like this and now black can continue not
not quite sure how Queen f7 maybe on I
don't know I mean I think white has some
dangerous player he's got Bishop b3
attacking do six or Bishop h3 if he
wants both is interesting and while it's
just a pawn at the moment I think h5 was
an interesting alternative galphin
Smoove is not not terrible or anything
but I think h5 was maybe a bit more
dangerous for black went to h5 and now
Bishop perm h3y at the bishop is
certainty nicely positioned
now look back to eight and rookie one
yeah efore is certainly one idea and
black centralizers and prepares for any
central play Bishop g4 yeah intending to
maybe capture and play g6 so on Black is
reacting in place queen to d6 now after
the capture here g6 is not a problem
anymore as the Queen can take yeah white
of constant didn't take on age five and
he played 92 which is some I think okay
there also was a form i think also an
interesting try and that it's also quite
quite principled this move you have
played f3 and II form that would be nice
to get this working the thing is black
will take and yeah probably you need to
play Knight takes a move like pawn takes
can really be simply answered by Queen
takes d4 and white has no particular
trick available here but sorry II for
takes Knight takes Knight X is
interesting it forces blacks reply he
needs to play queen of eight now that's
the only move where else would she go to
cover the CERN this Bishop you need to
go here which is not the end of the
world to go back to evade and now chalo
White has more than one interesting try
one is 95 attacking b7 and at the moment
attacking before in them yeah this is
interesting very unclear position Black
has the somewhat offside 90m which
really makes White's play interesting
from a structural point of hugh white is
not in great shape with this isolated
pawn but he's got dynamic ideas so he
for was was interesting it's not bad at
all he played 92
bad like took and now back to d7 the
night on b6 wasn't doing so much anyway
so he gets it back and maybe to have
eight or prepare f5 yeah girl fans next
move from its night to inform not sure
that I like that too much but it's it's
probably not leading to any any instant
trouble i I really don't like that he
exchanges this somewhat somewhat clumsy
looking night but yeah it's not so easy
to suggest alternatives it could have
played some slow moves like let's say
nights you 12 d 3 not 2 d 2 nite c 1 to
2 d 3 maybe this kind of slower slow
moves maybe even 93 f 495 yeah maybe a
maneuvering type of approach yeah well
not f4 is necessarily bad just don't
like it don't like it so much after the
capture white is threatening to play a 5
this is certainly what he what he had
seen and aren't just prevents this by a
by drastic means when I'm playing at
five which is okay takes Knight takes
and now I'm girl from played rookie five
this was the idea behind night f4 to
establish a strong point on d5 and this
wave activate the rupiah damn now Anna
doesn't have much choice up to this
point I think the game is quite quite
logical he took here recaptured and rook
takes d5 yeah maybe here girl fans
should have gone for d takes d5 it's
very difficult to assess I must say I am
invested a bit of time to try to to
evaluate that but I'm not
if F takes it really is a mistake it's
it's possible he took with the f-bomb
maybe you should have done that it's
it's maybe this is better it's obviously
very sharp with those for advanced pawns
but yeah maybe you should have done that
afternoon for our queen e7 just to show
a possible line let's say a queen f2
covering the pawn rook f8 Brooke f1 you
know why does some intending to to push
on the King side while black my play
move like c5 intending c4 with its own
attack this is very very sharp this
position and I'm not really sure how to
evaluate it it seems let's say unclear
to me I know unclear as a bit of yeah
like chickening out not really
committing to an evaluation but my
analysis time is limited I really think
it's terribly complicated and can go
either way in the game I think after the
f porn capture um yeah I think Arnold is
slightly better really he played Queenie
7 and it's interesting to play Queenie 6
as well just immediately um attacking
the pawn this also seems quite
comfortable for black it's just the
simple fact that any Queen move like
really sick sore Queenie 7s winning a
temple on the pawns you cannot really
give up one of them and after the the
cover of the pawns he plays rook evade
and now it's on the only open file and
this counts for something and remember
what I said when you push the pawn to a
3 imagine a position where some pieces
are traded at the end we have heavy
pieces on the board this pawn is super
annoying if the queen is entering the
position this king will suffer against
this or due to the students pawn and we
could really quickly see
that why this is struggling him he
played h5 probably also there was time
travel involved in not quite sure the
clock times you seem very inaccurate
Queen f7 a good move trying to enter
with the Queen and if the Queen and
rogue enter wats position it will get
hairy for this game due to the bond you
played h6 and it seems that this yeah
not it's not them it's a it's very
tricky now queena 3 the Queen enters and
here maybe he should have tried h7 to
trying to muddy the waters first this
move and then rookie one this is maybe
somewhat better than what he played but
black is certainly better here they can
also just take two white can try a six
but this is all a very fishy now this is
what you played and this after the
capture is just just worse in comparison
Black now has an healthy porn him and
white cannot take on age six at all you
know after this its queen bee three can
this is already a mate and exactly what
i was talking about look at this the
onion i come on here and why this
absolutely defenseless CM it's it's a
maid coming so you cannot take on age
six you played e6 rook e8 g5 check and
the check FG a girlfriend already
resigned it was very surprising to me
how quickly the position fell apart i
think it really seems like he he must
have taken with the deep on this already
looks very very tricky maybe i'm there
is some improvement here but I really
didn't didn't see it it seems difficult
to find anything that
is giving up the h-bomb how how would
you try make a sacrifice out of that
it's a it's just just difficult maybe
really d takes d5 was the way to go with
a very complicated and unclear position
yeah an important to inform for Vichy
yet very bad start with two losses and
girl fans tournament wasn't exactly
great before but now it's really rotten
he lost two games two drawers and it's
not looking good okay let's go to the
next game what is the next game okay
let's go with Jeff they're both good and
I don't have any any particular order
here I just take the oil as it listed on
the official site Carlson against Cara
wanna the world champion against the
young Italian player hasn't been very
yeah he was lucky really against
Nakamura escaping from a really really
lost position but it's not yeah yeah you
you have to earn the points anyway even
if you are lost so let's see what
happened in this game of carson is
scoring a lucky win again nor if he's
scoring her deserved when I even loses a
game losing a game would be interesting
as well he hasn't lost a classical time
control game in Nam and I almost hello
nine-month somewhere in the summer he
lost the last game let's see what
happens the Berlin defense young
wouldn't it be nice if for just one
tournament they would Bend this opening
yeah it would be nice to see more yeah
some other openings maybe a Sicilian
here and there but ok the Berlin is
really a good opening what can you do
Calvin is playing d3 not going for the
end game and after
g5 exchanging on c6 so it's a the exact
same line that are not played against
Nakamura and he lost later and I didn't
really like the line and I so I still
don't think that this should trouble
black too much let's see what happens
it's a very very simple chess a three
yeah this pin is prevented 97 yeah this
is a move that maybe need some
explanation it's not apparent my black
water moves the night again but in fact
the term is the start of a very typical
maneuver black very often once a night
on deform or night influencing the
default square so the knight on f6 is
not really well placed in that respect
and what it wants to do is reposition
itself to e6 97 f 86 this is one idea or
sometimes in comparable positions you
sometimes play Knight b8 even pawn to c5
and Knight to c6 this is a bit wrong
water painted them but you get the idea
the night wants to go why Abby 8 or f8
to e6 or c6 to gain influence on the d4
square it's also matter of look at the
worst piece the knight on f6 is just not
doing anything it looks at this square
the square the square it's just not
doing anything so this makes some sense
Bishop e3 yeah black does not want to
take here because the half-open fr might
give widely little something he just
retreated to d6 which also fits to the
general idea to play c5 and regroup the
night to whatever square we see that in
the game 93 c five castles and now is
playing the mansion regrouping all in
all it's
hard to believe that white should get
something here 92 96-well 96 seemed more
logical to me but this is not a bad move
it it just acknowledges the fact that
whites only the real palm break is f4
and well why not put it on G 696 was
also possible but it blocks the bishop
he obviously intended to develop the
bishop and now nitey to the others
insists on playing a form as mentioned
being the only porn break and after 27
chat tags and therefore we see exactly
this spawn break plate young black top
yeah of course you cannot allow f5 takes
and takes and rook takes and draw a grid
no they didn't agree to a draw it looks
very dull this position at first I
thought I looked at exactly this
position right when I returned home
today and I was thinking wow this is
really nothing but yeah look at the game
it's it looks like nothing but in fact
there are some interesting points in
this position yeah what what is blacks
idea what would black like to do the
only thing that prevents this position
from being totally equal is that white
has this pawn on e4 black would like to
challenge the pawn and best with d5 and
to exchange deep warned against deep on
this would be nice it would also be nice
to exchange f porn against a pawn but
this is not so easy to accomplish he
wants to really play d5 and this is what
I wanna play b6 and Jim I'm not sure
maybe this is already gives white a
little something
some it's amazing an alternative would
have been to to just slowly first
prepare short castles this is the other
issue where so why blacks King are going
to go Castle short Castle long if you
cancel short one problem is that Queen
aged 5 and rook age for these kind of
ideas can get tricky also Bishop b2 to
c3 anthem I don't know short castles
looks a bit shaky and yeah maybe you
want to Casa long but if you want to
Casa long how do you prepare d5 with c5
hanging well he played b6 queen age 5
good move and now d5 playing exactly
what he had intended and it seems that Y
term gains something here by means of D
for this is what cars and plate and now
we're already in a position where black
has to solve some problems it's not the
end of the world or a big trouble or
anything but it's already a position
with some tension in it I think I'm
right here black only has one move
really he needs to push what what else
is there yeah and now we see that this
Bishop only three which at the moment
it's not looking too great might be a
real force to reckon with later simply
because in this port configuration the
dark squares have been weakened if you
just imagine this Bishop on f 2 g-3
Queen only five and if the King goes to
the queenside know you know this Bishop
is has been improved considerably over
the last couple of moves as the dark
squares have been weakened and this is
also the reason why cards now is not
playing a 5 which is the constant choice
of computer engines I had to check this
with Houdini and also
you if you look at the default ICC
engineer stockfish they all want to play
you five and yeah i understand it gain
space you know f7 is somewhat weak you
might have chances to play on the King
side but it makes this Bishop really a
bit of a stupid piece yes I know white
can try to activate it like this but
it's still somewhat blocked by the e5
pawn and this is why I think Carson has
not played a 5 you played b3 trying to
open up the position more and at the end
emphasize the strength of the bishop
kawana plate Quincy 60m and this might
already get him into trouble it said
it's quite quite cunning that that those
normal moves some tend to get tricky the
comp wants to play rook c8 but this is a
very difficult move for a human to play
as you simply saying okay my king will
I'm staying in the center what what are
you doing about it maybe black can't
Castle short anyway in the near future
but this is a move that it's difficult
for a human to do our I'll show you why
Quincy 6 seems to be tricky to better
understand what what the issue is
Carlton just played rook f1 and threaten
to take on f7 so like only has one move
he needs to Castle long this is what he
did and now Carl yeah he just took on c4
black must take with the queen of course
Genesis very simple yeah and now he just
sacrificed the exchange Bishop takes
rook takes and at first you might think
okay yeah well they exchange what's the
problem the problem is that white has
very strong threats already and black
needs to attend to that
if he grabs pawns let's say he i had
just for example there is Bishop f4 and
as I mentioned this is just a force like
has this move to reckon with it is
absolutely no defense I mean besides
Bishop f4 the check check is also
winning if you get this check this is a
bit too much black has absolutely no
defence IAM and the same thing happens
after Queen Queen to a two on almost any
other move from black leather black
retreats to c6 there's also simple
capture here or karana played is the
best movie played rugby seven yeah now
town took it and took third d5 pawn and
we are getting to a position where white
at the moment has two pawns for the
exchange but the main point of course is
this king it's just very very tricky to
play this position the king is
permanently week a permanent problem and
in addition white has a very dangerous
deep on the combination of the bed king
and the deep one makes this position
absolutely murderous to handle he played
them g6 now karana and this seems like
him a good defense he couldn't for
example on take on c2 you know Queen g4s
winning here really winning instantly
the singers flagship Blanco if he goes
here just starting with some easy stuff
the deep one is decisive you can just
give checks and at the end push the porn
home no way to defend against that
if black after the check goes back here
you just take on g7 and win yeah through
gave aid check something like that check
check it's just a disaster like really
AM has very little choice g6 is a good
defense check Minji for check and King
over to c7 what else Queenie 6 yeah I'm
intending to get this Bishop in and also
intending d6 check winning the Queen and
Queen e5 ya a7la really normal threats
like only has this move King be 70
plated in this position maybe calzon
could have played them a bettens you
played check we need seven check which
keeps an advantage and still poses lots
of problems they also was Queen f6 which
is maybe even better it has the
following idea if blacks black plays
normal looking new flag ook c8 you just
push the deep on and yeah you need to
move the rook right not necessarily
that's also this one but here white can
play any sound check King moves and
again d6 and it's very tricky for black
white skiing is really safe black only
has a single check on you one and that's
it and what is black exactly doing
against the further pawn push note that
it's it's also possible the right
circumstance to just play Bishop g5 yeah
let's say black just place a nothing
move
means is hard to do so playing a nothing
move but then this and Bishop g5 will
promote the pawn check yeah this was
played it's not a bad move maybe Queen
f6 was even better but here blacks
defense is not not easy at all still
Queenie for intending possible t6 check
and can run up late Queen d7 G sash
check and King a6 all this is all these
are only moves and our Bishop f4 keeping
this important pawn rook c8 gap the rook
needs to get out of a jade get into the
game teenage to and Roxy for mother
seems completely completely logical here
um white had to head alternatives he
played the bishop to g3 which seems fine
he also could have played the Queen e7
here this is what I have what I analyzed
it looks um or let's say Queenie to be
527s a bit more precise the idea being
that black is now forced to trade this
is this was my idea thought that at
first I thought white is just winning
but that's not the case black has the
the funny defense look g8 he needs to
get get to g8 to avoid we should be a
winning yeah now White's play something
like we should be six and it looks
really good for white but note that
blacks king will go to d7 and then it's
not an automatic win the pants do not
promote itself why does the only one
playing for win of course but it's not
clear that he really is winning so when
this was not so on so great Bishop g3
seems better
that's a good waiting muth slide
improving move and now rook c8 was
played he just retreated um this is I
think a mistake to be us it seems that
b5 was was a better defense this is very
similar to what i just showed if white
goes Queenie 7 we actually have a um
yeah different to move on a leading to
the same position basically the bishop
been on g3 instead of f4 and if queen is
heaven is not winning outright and I
don't think it is then this is the
better defense what has all kinds of
ideas to to keep the pressure on with
Leela moves like like a three for
example this is not doing much but what
exactly is black smooth now he is
constantly defending against the deep
own and the threats against the king um
so this is much tougher then what
happens in the game after he retreated
the rook why did this check and this was
the problem what is black supposed to do
now you cannot play Queen B 5 as some 7
winning a d7 disrupt ehm no I just move
yeah this move I'm sorry I screwed up my
own my own annotation here this is much
better to to play this happen next and
black cannot prevent it you can take yet
and white as a triple pawn but well one
of those Deep Ones is enough the d6 bond
what will promote so this move is not
possible even then what about b5 yeah
this runs into a 4 not very very nice
position black essentially only has one
move he needs to go back and now why it
has the C porn involved and this is now
yeah I think like is like is lost here I
don't think there is a defense with the
sea pawn in the game it's too much this
is excellently protect
it and you get the seaport in the attack
you get the a point into the attack
Quincy 6 and queen bee three and carbon
is playing this absolutely precisely if
black takes here d7 end an overload of
the Queen take him check right of course
promotes with the check and has an extra
bishop and the end Black cannot take and
this is the the constant problem what
can just push even the a pond yeah just
pushing it of course black can not take
it look at this for example and Jack and
it's a disaster those pawns really
really am yeah completely bulldoze black
gap a five plate king to be seven and
now c5 yeah pushing everything forward
here also d5 was winning but what what
he played is completely sufficient to c5
King c8 take stakes and here here's
another very important position where
Carson shows that he's just an excellent
um calculator it's you could if you
don't calculate precisely you could say
okay let's take this pawn I'll win that
and maybe you do but he just played it
even more forcefully played d5 like only
has one move Queen takes and now I
played Queen a four and this is just
deadly it threatens d7 check the
threatens some Queen ahead Queen g-form
it's a terrible crossfire and black as
defenseless he played rookie three check
check check is this is all fours check
and now the deep on check gets involved
rookie seven and now the simple but nice
finishing finishing touch Queen Jayde
check and tier kawana resigned after
Queen takes of course white check at the
end emerges with an extra bishop yeah
what can you what can you say it's just
an excellent game Carlton may be made
maybe a slight in accuracy with this
with Queen where is it Queen somewhere
check when you self check maybe Queen f6
was stronger but we are talking about
very small nuances here I'm really
amazed that out of this frankly speaking
completely dull position he got this
this great play and I really don't
understand how it happened it's a it's
it's quite it's quite amazing maybe a
Kara wanna hear really should have
played differently with f6 and short
castle it's it's amazing around here
very quickly he has some problems i mean
it's it's already tricky to play and
somehow it seems it shouldn't be but it
happens sometimes cars really managed to
to get get excellent play out of
deceptively simple end and and
harmless-looking positions it's it's it
smells amazing yeah with this wind is on
three and a half points out of form of
course the SS nakamura game i know but
what what can you say about the 3100
something performance just an amazing
result in the final round which is going
to be played tomorrow if i'm not
mistaken he will face
XO champion vishy anand and let's see
what cars is doing its got the black
pieces though not not easy to to do
something especially if Annad it's not
playing for for anything big you know
you don't know maybe I'm not a sorry
trying hard to to to get a win and
somehow make this tournament a result
bearable I don't know all right but
there's still one game left and it was
an interesting game Aronian against
nakamura they really play very
interesting chess in this tournament
that's there's some very little they're
very few games with with little content
I don't think there was a really dull
game maybe one game but otherwise very
interesting chess okay let's let's start
we have neither three and the cameras
playing the Kings Indian very fighting
choice and they're only are opting for
them for the fianchetto variation here
of course not camera select the chance
to play a group route but he didn't he
obviously had prepared the king's indian
and and stuck stuck to this preparation
a six the the panel variation age three
yeah one of the main lines white can
also play em immediately for b3 there
are many lines h3 looks a bit mysterious
at first sight maybe but the idea is
that after later a form you want to
prevent Bishop g4 from happening if you
look at this just for this is an ok move
but just to show the general idea if
this Bishop is exchanged against the
night then black might get to play
against the default porn d 4 is the
sensitive spot in the Kings Indian for
white he has pushed all three center
points
and it's very important to keep a good
control over deform and h3 is a move
designed to improve long-term control
over deform it's a lot easier to grasp
concept maybe but it's very typical for
the Kings Indian fianchetto just a
coincidence i had to exactly the same
thing today in a tournament game that
maybe i'm going to show in a couple of
days of f the time because it was an
interesting game ok rugby aid plate this
is of course one idea of a 696 clear be
eight for the rook and prepare b5 as a
counter play this b5 idea gains in
strength after white as fianchetto would
be five is rarely a good idea to prepare
if white has played a classical set up
with e for Bishop e2 but in the
fianchetto be five is very often a
feasible idea efore b5 and here um
aronia plays an interesting news that i
didn't know really played d5 i am only
have superficial knowledge of the
exchange of the fianchetto variation
while ago when Boris a brook is really
top grandmaster released his deform the
repertoire series I started to study the
fianchetto Kings Indian he had to
analyze the deeply in the book ended
really impressed me like the positions
and I thought well let's study this
opening to be honest I completely forgot
everything that I looked at them in the
book and can hear there are other
possibilities like e5 or or taking
everything's possible this is a rare
move but I move that as I have checked
in the database has gained some
popularity recently it intends after
before this makes sense black can also
play 9 a-5 it's not a terrible move
but after be 492 like now place 95 where
else to go taking c4 wide attends to
play 94 maybe exert some influence over
the c6 career at the moment of course
efore hangs and cyn so White's movers
quite logically covers both pawns in
black played c6 yeah a very typical
feature of the panel variation here and
the the slide is the night on a five it
is of course somewhat off side and the
fate of this night usually decides the
game if black manages to make some to
make some sense out of this night then
he normally is at least okay if like
somehow does not manage to make sense
out of the piece then why it is usually
better because yeah well there's this
old rule if one piece is bad the whole
position is bad that it's may be
exaggerating a bit but yeah it's not so
far ironia played that ft for this is in
fact a novelty in in a couple of games
or two games night etudie forms played
the other night it's a slight difference
of course and I like the move maggot not
ft for it tries to provoke a commitment
of the sea porn black also could've
played c5 he took in took on d5 he could
have played c5 which is interesting
simply for the fact that it yeah it
addresses the a5 not a problem is if
white wants to play Yeah right wants to
avoid night b3 exchanging it you would
need to go to f3e but after that black
has at least the b3 move here that in
fact makes some sense out of tonight and
like takes Knight takes
and black get some this Bishop so maybe
white would even play here and then you
can exchange it the only issue about
this position is it's not clear to me
that black is really okay you have
gotten rid of this this night but in the
process you've given yd half open a file
there's always the apron to worry about
you cannot easily defend it this is a
weakness and white yeah of course has
some space advantage in the center it's
benoni structure after all and if white
is given some time he will certainly
start the steamroller it's not happening
immediately you need to prepare it but
I'm not so I'm not so positive about
blacks play here and I think when a
camera did was okay he took on d5 but
now he played Queen c7 and I don't
really like that one it's of course very
easy to to say after looking at the game
it seems that he five is the better way
to get counter play in fact this is
similar to the game but Quincy seven is
not such a positive move here the main
problem is what is White's next move he
really would love to play b3 Bishop b2
completing its development and the thing
is that now b3 is not so great after a
five-night a three for instance Bishop
f5 and black can even think of returning
the night in the near future here black
seems perfectly oh right he gets very
active pieces so after this it's not so
clear what why should do here se5 is an
idea anyway moving the night or chasing
the night away and then Bishop f5 maybe
this is the solution and this
it's possible Quincy 7 has the drawback
and we see this after be three now we're
now in play d5 and I think we may be
really should play this move it looks
weakening I know but I don't think you
can afford to play any slow stuff if you
play em some moves like you know first
of all note that this is not great
because of 96 and one here can take yeah
probably probably a three is even better
yeah that's even better what I was
trying to say is if black plays slowly
let's start with that move for instance
opening up the bishop diagonal white
just develops Bishop b2 and then
something like rook e1 night f4 and at
the end the week epon will be a problem
white even can play a quick h-bomb push
it this is this a very bad position but
ok for a good player this is quite a
parent you need to do something here
like not play any slow move e 5 was what
he did and this was bit too quick and
now a 3 the thing is this be three moves
really has right has helped wide a lot
the inclusion of Quincy 7 NB 3 was
clearly to white advantage because now a
3 is just very strong black has a hard
time now to keep this pawn he needs to
take and now the important point is that
white did not recapture the plate Bishop
detune and maybe this is what nakamura
underestimated this I can only speculate
here the big problem is that now white
is going to catch on a three with the
rook and in the meantime he threatens to
take on a five now let's say 'if i for
example my takes and now gets this
night for game winning this is why black
basically needs to retreat the night and
now after Luke takes white just has an
excellent position he's got to porn
Islands my black is for I'm sorry 33 but
in addition it's reborn islands but this
is just permanently week and also of
course the ape on this is already very
tricky to play for black lady five and
of course why does entering on c6
looking eight and night before yeah the
night looks nice on c6 but this is also
a nice square plate a five and queen a
to ya here maybe 95 was a bit more
precise as possible after Queenie to a
to maybe a Nakamura should've played
Bishop be 6 cm getting more control over
the d5 square it's the very nice
position for white but I think in the
game after Bishop f5 95 take check very
much forced and then before I think it's
even worse here we see that the apron
might become the decisive factor if
white is able to capture on a five under
favorable circumstances the combination
of this bishop and the pawn will be a
big problem he took on a tree and now
look to be one yeah and now black has
this problem what is threatening to take
he played Bishop f5 back
and now rupee to ya here Bishop d7 was
played it was I think in this position I
need to check my notes am what's in this
position yeah in this position here he
was an interesting an interesting spot
and the computer has an interesting
suggestion yet wants to play Quincy
eight which at first looks a bit strange
but it has an interesting idea and the
ideas if Wyatt now takes on a 5 which
looks like an absolutely normal move
first you think arising wide winning
black has a very good reply he has got
95 and this is not so easy to spot for a
human if you look at this taking the
exchange you are yeah that first might
have some doubts if this is the best for
white and if you look at in poor detail
you see that black is actually already
am the one calling the shots 93 Bishop
h3 this is not fun at all the best line
according to the computer is a 693 rugby
seven-night f2 and it already is very
very tricky for white it seems that c5
for some reason it's a draw it will tell
me why I don't ask me why I would like
to know but it's a very strange position
what I'm getting at is that this is
surprisingly tough defense so does this
mean that Quincy 8 is a solution to
blacks problems in fact it isn't what
has a strong move c5 yeah and this is a
move that you can I think I only really
spot if you have seen night c5 because
after details white X and we have
a comparable position but without the
square c5 available and this means that
white keeps us advantage the apron is
just very strong 96 for example again
trying to give up the exchange but I can
ignore it he can play move like would be
six for example and yeah this will
continue white is better the computer is
actually giving white a very big
advantage but it's not completely easy
to play him I can i'm pretty sure that
human players have their difficulties in
this position so while Quincy eight was
an interesting try Bishop d7 was played
instead and now be takes and now the big
differences if black now tries to to
give up the exchange you need to take
with the rook and not with the Queen and
you don't have the Queen now near the
king of on this light squares so that a
six is just securing White's windmill a
seven coming this is pretty much lost
Bishop c6 was played and 93 yeah White
has excellent play on the queenside 95
and Bishop e3 yeah after ye for white
absolutely does not mind to give up an
exchange he's just playing a six and
here playing group look to be sabra's
very strong it's not difficult to find
but still very strong it gives up the
exchange he didn't take it even but if
you look at this position here something
like that this is such just not
defensible the combination of
drawing this really really long the
combination of night b5 Green 88 Bishop
e7 is decisive absolutely no chance or
black he's got zero counterplay here he
didn't take it plate Quincy eight and
now aronian took on the form yeah white
now is really totally winning and after
this capture and Quincy form he could
just take on d3 for an exchange and now
went back to be three the a pond is just
just the winner here note that this
Bishop only three is keeping the whole
King side together Queen takes Queen e2
covering the spawn and preparing a seven
Quincy six yeah and here there that's
more than one win he played a seven
simple and strong and no d5 yeah intern
here welcome Nakamura allowed an instant
winner I mean white was winning anyway
but now rook g7 was played and this is
just just finishing the game off really
quickly I think the computer already
gives a mate f king takes check Bishop
t4 check king age 6 yeah you need to go
there if you will go to g8 there's
Queenie 7 coming check that's a bit too
much
so you need to go to h6 check check here
taken g5 there is at least rupee 6 at
g4s also quite nice threatening made
into yeah this is cannot defend that
actually okay so we went king age five
and now check g4 see it's the deal it's
made in five moves now King to h4 check
check check another check check Ruger
three yeah and faced with the prospect
of King g5 check check here grenade for
mate Nakamura resigned so Nakamura
losing the second game in a row after
the really devastating loss yesterday
it's no surprise that he lost again to
be honest it's psychologically very
difficult to lose such a game and but
also give very big credit to aronia and
he played an excellent game you cannot
pinpoint in a mistake on Whiteside if
you look at it with a super strong
engine it points out some slight
slightly inaccurate use but this is
really minor an excellent game and we
see in the tournament standings I think
it's pretty clear it's a pretty clear
display of the current state of the
chest top rankings as cars honest
leading with an enormous score three and
a half out a form and Aronian right
after that with three out of four and
all other players have a minor score at
least minus one even minus two so really
the word number one and what number two
places where really yeah uncontested
let's say no one is going to doubt that
calzon is the number one and aronia and
the number two
very strong play by both both players
yellow tomorrow we have the the final
round and let's see what what happens
aronian certainly can try for for
another win I'm not sure who is playing
playing playing kawana and I'm not quite
sure I only know that Carlton needs to
play against against Arnold yeah well
let's hope for yet another good round
tomorrow this was very good very good
chess very good and interesting chest
thanks for watching I hope you liked it
as well bye